The Joe Rogan Experience I spent most of
my from 14 to 25 in jail yeah I do know
that I spent like a ton of time at 16 I
was charged as an adult for a charge and
what did you do it was supposed to be
the first time I've ever actually talked
about the charge
um I just say it was it was a heinous
crime admittedly it was horrible we
robbed a couple of guys for some weed
but they called the police because we
took some money and some stuff and it
was it was an armed robbery I mean we
went in there with a gun I regret it
every day of my life Joe you know I mean
I was a kid now I'm not making an excuse
but I would like to paint the picture
that I literally did not have pubic
hairs I'm a 15 year old kid when it
happens you know and I still feel
horrible about it but because the state
of Tennessee has a zero forgiveness
policy for violent offenders I've
carried that unexpungible felony
for 20 something years
it prohibits me from getting houses it's
prohibitive it's it's put me in I mean
if life insurance homeowner insurance is
higher if I can get it at all I can't
get life insurance at all just because
they just they have a most of them won't
give you a decent policy as a felon
um dude I can't volunteer at the YMCA
the young men's a Christian Academy
won't let me you know just um me and my
wife just got turned down for a house
I'm in a place in life where I go to buy
my dream home guard gated community golf
course man I'm crying Joe they accept my
offer everything's going crazy I'm like
this ain't gonna be real
they turned me around say no the golf
course won't let a felon be a part of
the community
you know and I'm I'm a [__] dude I'm
a 15 16 year dude but the idea that
there's just this one definition this
one solid yes or no
this is a thing you you have the mark on
you right and it's not an individual
with individual circumstances that's so
ridiculous and that's not what a human
being is supposed to be about right
we're not supposed to be about that
we're supposed to be about understanding
situations right and when there's a
child that does something really [__]
stupid and knows it forever you don't
think you could have done that this is
what I would tell to people if you were
in that same Community you were with
those same influences this was the
reality that you were born into you
don't think you could have gone with
those other kids that were gonna Rob
someone with a gun you could have don't
lie to yourself you could have they're
not unsavable human beings right and
then
that's why I focus all of my
philanthropy philanthropic efforts with
the juvenile at home you know we sunk a
quarter million dollars into there for
my last Hometown show I sold out my
Arena big craziest night ever you know
[__] the hometown Arena how big is it
your hometown it just hits different
yeah you know what I'm saying when
you're like oh no this is home you know
what I'm saying like oh they like me at
home yeah you know for me it's Boston
yeah yeah when you play the garden right
yeah God crazy dude I just couldn't
imagine the emotions of just like dude I
[__] ate [__] at this Comedy Club
here I [__] [__] talk [__]
kickboxing and [__] out here for [__]
20 bucks a session and here I am
standing in the [__] Garden City I
was like I was sitting two blocks away
from the juvenile I was in George I mean
uh Joe and I'm sitting there Joe and
they and I went and talked to the kids
before I went metal Mall spent
Thanksgiving with them before the show
fed them and sat down with them and said
look y'all I know a couple of y'all been
here for a year or two just like I was
building a studio in here and I'm
building trade programs and I got y'alls
back man we worked out with a lot of
lawyers we put it we worked with the
state now they're building a new
juvenile that we're going to sink
millions of dollars into and have an
Aftercare program I'm gonna do
so much for at-risk youth in Nashville
because my whole life changed in that it
was the most
I look back at it and I talk about it so
much that sometimes I desensitize myself
for how traumatic it really was I spent
my 15th 16th 17th 18th 19th and 20th
birthday incarcerated
straight like most kids are like my
daughter will inevitably by the grace of
God get a car on her 16th birthday you
know like the dream [__] you know with
the Rhythm [__] it's gonna be a big
moment you know it's going to be [__]
crazy you know but I got you know they
didn't even give me an extra piece of
cake for dinner you know what I mean
like you know I didn't have a guard tell
me happy 15th or 16th birthday you know
what I mean you don't get a family visit
like
I missed High School completely
I have I have I think I was in high
school for like I think we actually
pulled the records like six weeks
you know what I mean
and then the only thing that turned that
[__] around for me was Bailey I was in
the revolving door of the judicial
system in and out
I knew I'd got a woman pregnant I'm back
in jail she's pregnant
she hates me we're not talking I'm a bad
human she's right I was a horrible human
and I'm sitting in there and that guard
knocks on my door May 22nd 2008 Joe
D Ford
it's count time I say what's up he goes
you had a kid today
and he walked away whoa dude it just I
still get emotional it was like it was I
don't know what
kind of it was like a Damascus Road
experience in the Bible like I
immediately Joe was like I've got to do
something to change I've got to quit
this [__] like I gotta figure it out now
I'm in the violent offender gang unit of
this jail
there's a sign on the door that you can
sign up for an education unit right but
nobody ever signed up for it because
it's like checking in you know what I
mean like in jail it would be like uh
your boy told the jail stories that was
in here with Bobby so you understand the
lingo is like they put you on the door
you'd sign up for the sheet of paper so
they get you out of the unit or if you
were scared you would sign up to get out
of the unit I've been in there for
[__] a year I mean uh [__] seven
eight months six months seven months
playing poker every day
chilling and immediately Joe wouldn't
sign up for that education unit got my
GED I didn't know what I was gonna do
but I knew that I was I was dead set on
not selling drugs ever again